alors j'ai eu si vous avez un ep qui
sort un mondial toujours là c'est ainsi
qu'est ce qu'un beau père oui il ya
quelques tiges des ministres nommés
c'est ton âge je t'en veux pas d'un
grand et gentil
alors donc il a single oui c'est ça
c'est je veux alors maintenant c'est un
envol de carrière en solo après des
critiques
bah ouais si j'ai passé trois années
assez incroyable concret des kids et
j'ai décidé de quitter l'aventuré ya non
moi je connais le producteur d'aidé qui
se lasser ils ont fait des tournées de
deux bagues à l'état c'est incroyable
c'étaient les trois plus belles années
de ma vie pour le moment en tout cas
et là je suis vraiment à fond sur la
création de mon album et de tous mes
petits projets qui arrivent très bien
c'est le single je veux
[Applaudissements]